clark county school district is
officially on pause tonight students are
out of class until next wednesday
because of a rise in covenant cases and
staffing shortages but ccsd has plans
they hope will keep students in the
classroom sasha loftis was at tonight's
board of trustees meeting and she joins
us now live with the message from
families and district leaders sasha yes
denise and brian a lot of people stood
up to share their frustrations tonight
over this pause in classes but district
leaders say the move is not a sign that
distance learning will return
they might just engage with drop another
night of impassioned pleas from ccsd
parents students and teachers please do
not shut us down after this five-day
pause i don't feel safe discussions
during thursday's board of trustees
meeting centered around the decision to
pause classes for five days due to a
search in covid 19 cases it's more than
just education many including michelle
blauer fear this could lead to a return
to distance learning which she says her
kids struggled with emotionally and
mentally it's super hard for these kids
to be on the computer all day long and
no social interaction but district
leaders say they're doing everything
they can to keep that from happening our
goal is to stay open and not shift to
distance education revisions to school
mitigation plans were presented and the
volunteer test to stay program was
announced which will allow students and
staff who were exposed to covid19 on
campus to test every other day and avoid
a five-day quarantine i'm going to tell
you right now
it's not good enough
but many say they want to see more done
and hope those responsible understand
what's at stake their decisions impact
the lives of our kids
the test to stay program will be an
option starting this coming wednesday
when kids return to class covid
retention bonuses were also approved
tonight meaning many full-time ccsd
employees will receive one to two
thousand dollars extra